hey guys how's it going I'm on my way to
Malibu right now Maddie in the backseat
windows are up my family's already there
I shot a bunch of videos today so I said
go ahead guys
I will meet you there so I can attempt
to get some work done but now I'm gonna
drive and stop vlogging because it's
very dangerous so do not blog and drive
Maddie did you go potty outside hi honey
look at you so just got here is this my
room the kitchen here this is super cute
oh I love this mirror I love with a dome
with a place no wait oh oh wait that
creeps me out
oh I almost lost my mind wait I'm so
confused
this is so weird I thought this was like
I didn't know what was happening really
big what is me - she twirls that's weird
- Jenna's what is how do i how do you
have a live look at a point easily like
a bath where this is the outside I'll
just close those a little super cute I'm
glad we made it little Matty was a very
good boy I think Matty might want to go
in here tonight
to see you Teddy uh it's an extra room
of crap sting oh um I bet in the daytime
this is really cool so many amazing big
windows 360 view please come upstairs
thanks Jenna kitchen jazz for sure
everybody yeah he's definitely a charred
ho look at in where it is in that I see
on your front seat yes that's over here
okay my eyes are closed look wait a
candle didn't you look at me
where are you I can't see you keep your
hands making me close my eyes they're
not close or not now close um oh sure
yelling at the dog the dog is getting
upset yeah Clooney hi
[Music]
Oh No
could we just say this tomorrow I'm
tired I'm very sleepy well why don't I
see it during the day
okay guys are closed okay my eyes are
closed look at me okay I'm walking cuz
close them are we going to do an
elevator eyes are closed
careful watch I just have to go to the
right okay if we get stuck in here I'm
gonna be very very upset
let's go sideways uh when you see during
the day scary really that is your first
tram ride commute look at you
hot oh we can just see right into the
house hello legal train running all
during dinner
oh my memories and pasta I don't like
that so I'm gonna needs a trim mat so we
decided to surprise our parents with a
little getaway here in Malibu so that's
why we're here and this place is awesome
great pick I can't say that I did
anything at all because I didn't even
help lo que Jen I'm BRE good at all
all right just you you contribute in
your own way yeah let him go potty
oh thank you wanna do laundry it's
outside hi interesting I feel like they
might have the Packard with that inside
um yeah Mae it's Malibu as you guys
probably saw from previous clip I don't
think I filmed anything too much
yesterday we are now on a little drive
up into the mountains it's seriously so
pretty I've never actually come here for
fun and I usually have shoots and stuff
in random locations and houses this is
cool so come here for fun scary Wow also
how do we get around them that's so far
under with their live you probably could
we're doing these solstice Canyon hike
it's not very long so we'll see I've
actually never done this before
very sad Maddie's not here or my baby
with that uh-huh I miss him so much my
pet we left it at home because it was
really windy and the last time we went
on a hike and it was windy it's really
bad for the little eyes so I didn't want
him to I didn't wanted to get dirt in
his eyes so this is the Maddie free hike
although it's give me a very nice hike
for him one day okay I think there's
actually a fire something to potentially
be concerned about because there's a
helicopter
I would hope but you have a lake that
you know what we'll keep an eye on yeah
yeah yeah but I told I'm alone but I
can't because I'm not into this I mean
there's like tons of helicopters up
there Wow I'm gonna drop it in scary
it's really scary
well yeah there are helicopters hovering
get not good
that's so so scary don't wait to that
maybe a job to do here come on I'm out
of here
[Music]
do you know buddy my gosh it's literally
right that is so scary
well that's that Canyon we were driving
up there earlier reading on Twitter is a
small brush fire near PCH latigo Canyon
firefighters are on the scene the two
acre brush fire sir here to the Malibu
cafe never been here before
super cute they have warm house-made
pretzels universal morning what no I
would just like some good look okay
those little umbrellas are over there
let's watch puree I signing out we will
take a thorough something Cornwall over
there yeah a huge half hat I'm just glad
we got out of blue fire zone that's a
super scary look at this are you kidding
me fantastic I don't look at you pattern
hey guys Sarah is there a hashtag for
this event
like we get it man we got your hashtag
look that said surprise bro out onto the
light drop anchor and enjoy him you can
enjoy a meal enjoy a meal this is so
cute I would love to do that
I would love to enjoy a meal I want to
row out and enjoy a meal so I am a
terrible dog mom and I forgot all of
Maddie's toys and clearly the last thing
that he needs is more toys but I found
an amazing camo blanket Pacific Coast
pet where is everybody at today I think
they might have left me very sad again I
got coffee Maddie what do you think your
new uh new leash where's Mary
where's Maddie got some cool sunset pics
tonight going for a little walk free we
taking the tram yeah the shrimp the tram
let's do it let's come in come in here
we go go love look how pretty oh it's
very pretty
Maddie are you happy about the
beautifulness of the sunsets look at him
just gazing all night off and twosies
chain all over the sunset shoot we miss
it okay very pretty
oh that's that's nice yeah that's only
halfway up halfway then good stuff in
your mouth big what do you have in your
mouth teenies he's very thirsty look at
that hey guys it is our last day in
Malibu with the fam it's a very legal
day there's a fire somewhere over yonder
I'm not sure where let me zoom in see if
you guys can figure out where this is if
I haven't figured it out already on
Twitter dad and PAH
go potty go oh he did oh good boy
there's the Fire Mountain beach rope
went there's Maddy he's camouflaged she
can't see him on the same yeah he loves
the carpeting good boy whoa he is a very
good job going up steps now okay wow
you're fast bud you're fast I can't keep
up with you Oh gross this is the Malibu
Malibu Creek State hike it's really
really pretty
daddy's really enjoying it just pulling
away over there Bree and Jenna are back
there getting some nice Instagram this
is where the fire was yesterday it
burned a pear no it wouldn't
mmm that's so crazy yes general I'm
vlogging for you and me okay Bri
Jenna's driving we're right on the other
side of the hill who are Riley besides
where we were hiking Bree look at you
you look very nice in your little
sweater dad you know your self at
I got well I didn't get it for brave but
we can share the sweatshirt okay I know
I love your boots well I look good well
I can't find my blackouts because jenna
doesn't know where they are
maximum white three persons are seven
there pounds if you overloaded it will
break yeah I'm not really everyone
account for how much you weigh it does
say if you overloaded you will write it
but it's just just walk it along this
highway super safe filming there isn't
actually this is great nobody wakes up
early on the weekends here in California
even the six before hey hey
this place for brunch is incredible I
can't believe you've never been here
before
never beautiful with you
and was here for dinner but I've never
come for brunch and what this is my
favorite meal are you happy with your
choices yes but one day to strawberry
they're all covered in chocolate hmm
jeez that's just too bad isn't it are
the Dolphins I thought it was a shark
and we'll look on my face I'm waiting
I'll be sitting wait oh there he is
think about strolling up the hill oh
gosh I'm so cool from breakfast
heading back we're picking up the pop
and watching Steelers I gotta shoot some
videos many times I said that I feel
like if I keep saying it I'm gonna
actually get it done quicker
hey zip it with some TVs look Maddy
what's this ball Hey
get get oh you look so cute oh you want
to sit on my lap here ready get this one
no that one buddy oh he's so wild this
vlog is gonna make absoluto sense it's
just a bunch of clips of random things
thank you what good my name is Mickel -
yeah Teddy you missed a cute dog he was
really cute because Becky's so long can
you see buddy hey you have a ball yeah
but he wants more this is my first ever
holiday gift guide now this is going to
be a guide of things that I saw online
that I thought were cool also things
that I might have bought this past year
that I think that you might actually
like